so another viewer submitted question
from Nolan Putnam what's the most
helpful habit you've created in regards
to screenwriting that's allowed you to
become a professional that's a great
question
is there one habit that's been the most
helpful probably we've talked about most
of them probably the most important
perspective has been to see it as
something I'm always learning and I'm
always growing and that's okay it's not
like I'm supposed to know it all and be
perfect at it and the things that I
write are gonna just be great
automatically and others are gonna love
them to see it more as it's an ongoing
quest of kind of a self development self
education I'm learning with everything
that I write what works better and and
and not as good so that it's like it's
like this this journey of development
that you sort of like are gonna enjoy
the journey as opposed to I have to get
to a certain place which it's easy to
feel that way because the world works
that way where I have to get the agent I
have to get the sale I have to get
something produced I have to raise the
money and make my movie like there's all
these goals we might have in the world
and a lot of times they're out of our
control and if you focus only on those
goals like what I can get what I can
achieve instead of what can i express
how can I just do what I decide I want
to do which is be a writer and be
learning and growing and find some
satisfaction in that journey because
when you turn it into there have to be
these quantifiable results in terms of
money or others reactions or whatever
then you're putting all your power in
this thing that may or may not ever
happen that you can't for sure make
happen no matter what you do so I think
that attitude it might seem
counterproductive because it's like well
to be successful you want to you know
professional you want to focus on the
professional goals right well you you do
to some extent and you are open to
feedback and you are listen you know you
are educating yourself I didn't say just
go in a hole and just do what you want
to do and never and shut the outside
world out I'm saying engage with the
world with feedback with education with
trying to understand and get better so
it's growth
but making it a positive growth for
yourself that is about making me better
and making my writing better not making
my results better because when you focus
on how do I give more how do I write
something that's really gonna impact
people more how do I do that how do I
figure out how to do it how do I get
better at it
you're then about giving to other people
and you will achieve success I believe
more when you succeed at giving more you
will get more automatically as opposed
to how do I get the success how do I get
the breaks how do I get the right person
to read it how do I get people to like
it it's more how do I create something
so wonderful that people will just
automatically like it I'm not even
concerning myself with that so it's like
taking the power into your own hands and
being about how you can improve your
stuff and yourself as a writer having
that approach I think is a is a strong
or healthier approach that's gonna lead
to success more than if you do it the
other way that's amazing because I mean
especially too if you do live here in
Los Angeles which you said that you know
necessarily have to but it definitely
helps you're bombarded every second with
reminders whether it's billboards or
someone going by you of somebody else
that's higher up on the proverbial sort
of food chain and it's kind of thrown in
our face and it's it's really wonderful
to think of the unplugging from that
because that's almost the anti sort of
culture here and and then I mean was
that something that was always a part of
your makeup or you had to learn oh no I
have to learn I mean I still it's again
it's like an everyday practice that
thing again right an everyday practice
of being about I'm just about the purity
of expression and growth and learning
and improving as opposed to the how do I
get the result that I want from others
it's because we don't naturally do it
that way we have to sort of like decide
that's how I'm going to approach this
instead right and I guess to in the last
few years and not to get too morbid but
we've seen people who have achieved
tremendous success obviously not be
happy and
then you have to ask yourself with him
why am I doing this yeah you know and it
has to be essentially and is is sort of
you know follow your bliss as it sounds
you know sort of bumper sticker on the
back it has to be about that because you
know we do see so many people that have
achieved these amazing results and the
end result for them showed that it
wasn't enough I do think it really is
about making the daily practice journey
writing whatever enjoyable being at
peace enjoying what you're doing each
day finding a way to make it that way so
that the journey is a positive journey
and not be so caught up in the
destination because if you enjoy what
you're doing you're gonna do it more
you're gonna do it better you're gonna
want to learn more but it comes from a
certain level of confidence and trust
that it's gonna it that it's what you're
doing is worthwhile and if you measure
that only in like money or career
statistics you know you may never get
there and you may always be insecure
about that so but people that want to
write usually there's more of like a
passion more of a purity of I just want
to do this for some reason and so if you
can really hold to that as opposed to
thinking that what what the results are
of doing it is what matters so much you
probably have a better time doing it
you'll be happier you'll be more
productive and prolific and the results
usually actually will follow from that
just real quickly when you before you
chose your major for film and television
what was your goal before that what was
your major when I first started college
I I experiment with being an English
major and you know thinking of writing
fiction poetry I because I experiment
with being a music major briefly but I
pretty quickly you know I took some of
the introductory film classes and I
realized this was the the medium that I
really wanted to try to write for and
and you said just that festivals really
aren't about the laurels I think I heard
you say in another interview I thought
that was actually beautifully put but
maybe I don't know maybe that's probably
true
you say you didn't say it but that goes
back to what we're talking about that
the end results you know it is not
really what it should be about and I
know it's easy to theorize that it and
and say these things and when then we
all have to kind of live in a reality
that is life and you're competing with
people all the time and that's something
that happens in preschool and that
happens in adulthood but to really have
something that we get from it that's
more than an accolade I think is do you
think that's what keeps you going
in terms of why you continue with it I'm
not sure what keeps me going to be
honest I mean I think that I keep going
like most writers because just like what
I do it's what I've decided I do what I
want to do and I have the I'm engaged
with the challenge of getting better and
and writing things that really fulfill
why I wanted to be a writer there are
the kinds of things I loved that I
wanted to create more of in the world
and yes part of that is well to get out
in the world I'm gonna need other people
to help me do that and finance it or
whatever but it's it's kind of like I
haven't achieved yet what I wanted to
achieve even though I've worked on some
big things and won awards and made a
living as a writer and stuff there's
there's a lot of the kinds of projects
that I always got into this because I
want to do that I still want to do those
and there will probably always be more
of those so I think there's just this
desire to create an Express that never
seems to quite go away and it's also
just a chosen field in a career at this
point so it's it keeps me going because
it's just the path that I'm on and and
have chosen I have no reason to unchoose
yeah I mean I could say the same for
film courage and it'd be great to have
videos get this amount of views but at
the end of the day it has to be about
you know the conversation like today's
conversation and that's worth it for us
that's what we do this for so I can see
even though I'm not a screenwriter you
know how it has to be there has to be
something else aside from you know we're
hoping Eric's video gets you know
millions of views or whatever it has to
be that did the process of it was
enjoyable which it has been so thank you
glad here yeah great as well yeah
you